I'm very excited my guest tonight has
starred in the social network and the
art of self defense as well as of course
the zombie land movies he can now be
seen in two brand-new movies that were
made available for streaming resistance
and vivarium or vivarium I don't know
he'll correct me instantly please
welcome Jesse Eisenberg Jesse how are
you
vivarium yeah great great great how are
you I'm doing pretty well I'm not sure
where you are what where are you right
now what are you inside it looks like
you're in a bunker yeah no no if only no
it's um I'm in I'm in Lawrence Kansas I
was like in Los Angeles for work then
this happened and we were trying to get
back to Indiana where we live and so we
rented like an RV so that we can kind of
isolate but also get back home I see I
see so yeah you're in an RV and you're
traveling across what sounds like the
Midwest in an RV with your wife and your
son is that right that's right
we're try to get back to Indiana to help
out at my mother-in-law's domestic
violence shelter who are losing their
volunteers because their volunteers are
college students so trying to get back
to help out there and we feel just like
you know totally helpless man that's
well that's very that's very nice of you
to make this effort to go and help out
obviously a great cause I'm gonna be
honest with you the the audio and the
audio and the video we're getting from
you is a pretty is a little sketchy but
um probably because you're in an RV in
Lawrence Kansas I I think it makes for
compelling television and so oh yeah
this is like I read about it do you
think this might be your season finale
this could be my finale finale no these
are grim jokes but it does look like I'm
talking to an astronaut in 1962 that was
one of the that was a great mission I
don't know what your funny about I mean
it was it was when they were just trying
to orbit the most you know
the first time I've been compared to gym
level yes exactly
well it's a fine comparison I've never
lived in an RV before is everything
functioning well in the RV are you okay
it's it's 99.9% perfect so so this is a
car and a house so like a million things
can go wrong and if you have ever had a
car or a house they often do this is
both and there's only one actually one
thing wrong in this entire thing which
is the the the valve for the human waste
is is the one thing that not functioning
well yeah wait yeah the valve that helps
control meaning drain the human right
waste into a receptacle is not working
that's precisely it that's precisely it
are you okay are you a handy fellow are
you able to fix this on your own if
something is going wrong I'm helpful and
immediately relaxed and all of my normal
fantasy worries are gone yeah and I
realize that my life is like just my
life is just completely consumed with
worries that I make up that have no
bearing on the world I see I see I'm
gonna confess something to you because
we've known each time I'm the same way
when everything a common Placid I'm
anxious but when the [ __ ] hits the fan
there's some part of me that thinks oh
I've reached equilibrium this is the
world I deserve to live in and that's
prom yes I think you gave the Freudian
analysis of our issue which is that we
have so much self-criticism or hey [ __ ]
or whatever when in the world is going
and we think yes this is exactly right